[Music]
[Music]
hello i'm sami zaydan this is counting
the cost on al jazeera you'll look at
the world of business and economics this
week
massive western sanctions are shutting
russia out of the international
financial system can it rely on its vast
oil and gas reserves will china step in
to help
more than a quarter of the world's wheat
exports come from russia and ukraine
grain prices have shot up raising
concern among importers around the world
will the conflict undermine global food
security
the european union expands sanctions on
myanmar to include a state-owned oil and
gas company it's a lucrative source of
income for the military will this put
pressure on the generals behind last
year's coup
[Music]
currency plunging to record lows the
stock market closed for days and
interest rates 20
russia has been reeling under the impact
of western sanctions that exclude some
of its banks from the swift payment
system and by the central bank from
accessing its huge dollar reserves
from oil giant exxon mobil to tech titan
apple international companies have
rushed to exit russia leaving moscow
financially and diplomatically isolated
bernard smith reports
nervous about whether debit and credit
cards might stop working as sanctions
bite some russians are stocking up on
cash
soon they'll begin to feel the financial
pain of their president's decision to
invade ukraine
with interest rates more than doubled 20
percent and the ruble plunging 30
percent against the dollar
we are planning to buy a flat so for us
it is very important we were hoping to
have a certain interest rate now it will
be totally different
of course i am worried first of all the
situation with the dollar is unclear and
what about food prices we are in a
dead-end situation there is no way out
for people russians have been promised
that central bank reserves of more than
630 billion dollars will help cushion
the economy from sanctions
but much of this money is in foreign
banks sanctions will make it very
difficult to get any of it back to
moscow
one russian economist told al jazeera
it's a completely unprecedented
situation for the central bank half of
these resorts are frozen and the other
half is likely to be unusable as well so
this is something where nobody really
can
imagine what's going on the central bank
says external conditions for the russian
economy have drastically changed
in a meeting about sanctions with
government ministers vladimir putin
described the western community as an
empire of lies
russia's economy is also taking a hit
from western firms running for the exit
bp the biggest foreign investor here is
abandoning its stake in oil firm rosneft
ups and fedex have stopped shipping
services half the passenger jets used
here are leased and those contracts are
being cancelled russia's political
economic and physical isolation from the
rest of the world is rapidly gathering
pace
bernard smith al jazeera moscow
russia says it's prepared for all kinds
of sanctions and it does have some
escape hatches centered around energy in
china the country's biggest earner the
oil and gas industry has been spared
most of europe relies on russia for its
energy needs another major consumer is
its southern neighbour china moscow and
beijing share warm ties and russia could
move towards chinese financial
initiatives set up to rival the west
they include greater use of the chinese
currency and the cross-border interbank
payment system
russia is also leaning on its
significant gold reserves and another
workaround could be greater use of
cryptocurrency
now from the city of groningen in the
netherlands i'm joined by francesco
jumeli francesco is deputy head of
department and associate professor of
international relations at the
university of groningen good to have you
with us so interestingly the west haven
has not put sanctions so far
on russian oil and gas how serious are
the sanctions without that component
sanctions without their component have
been unprecedented unprecedentedly very
serious um
only one week ago or slightly before the
the military operation started very few
would have considered that imposing
sanctions on the reserves of the central
bank were actually a serious option so
many people would have said listen until
you touch the energy in the gas sector
there are the oil and gas sector then
very likely the impact is not going to
be feasible but with the amount of
relevance of the reserves from the
central bank and the number of banks
that have been also put under
that scrutiny and
because these are cumulative effects the
number of people that have been uh
targeted by the sanctions for the freeze
of assets from the united states the
united kingdom and the european union
combined with all the efforts of the
international community to try to close
the loopholes for possible sanctions
evasion then the impact is nevertheless
very serious what's happening now is
that um possibly the sanctions from the
central bank are going way beyond what
the energy sector could have done
there's also been this swift ban on
russian banks
some analysts have said that when a
country looking back at other examples
when a country has had a swift ban put
in place it can lose up to 30 percent of
its foreign trade is that sort of
prediction or number realistic when it
comes to a country as big as russia
um
it is it is realistic but it wouldn't be
only because of the swift that is an
important thing to clarify zwift is only
a messaging system so it does not allow
for payments it makes payments faster it
makes payments and the communication you
know bank to bank much cheaper and very
secure and fast but it doesn't make the
payment in itself what's going on now it
is
up on the swift which is a short-term
cost and disruption of the system there
is also a number of listing of all the
banks the freeze of payments from all
the banks that is what makes the
sanctions much more tangible and indeed
we can we're likely to see something
that goes beyond 30 percent if this
continues in this way the question is
how the the beyond the 30 percent
franchise that's a surprising number yes
because again this is commutative effect
this wouldn't be on the zwift it would
be zwift and the reserves of the central
bank what happens with the reserves
being frozen is that the ruble loses
value and if the ruble loses value then
anything that russia was importing
becomes extremely more expensive and of
course there is then a a trickle-down
effect and community effect of all these
measures all together all right so a
follow-up quick follow-up on that
because you mentioned the central bank
sanctions
are they going to be able to manage the
ruble we've already seen it take a
plunge after the first day of the
invasion of ukraine
this is
something that also i think and many of
us thought it was not going to be done
precisely because of the magnitude now
this was this is also something that
russia and the central bank of russia
have been preparing for so for instance
the exposure to the dollar went down
from 40 to 15 percent in only a few
years which means that this was
something that they were uh preparing
for as much as the increase in the
reliance on the rabinbi so the chinese
currency that is very very important as
well what um
what we
we have seen also is a number of
measures something that we had not
predicted for instance since the energy
market is still open for trade what
russia has done has asked or forced
uh companies having revenues from the
sale of energy to put basically to
invest those resources in buying rubles
substantially so they're asking the
private sector to substitute for the
role of the central bank all right let's
look on the other hand the other side of
this question russia has been obviously
preparing for this it's reduced its
reliance over the years on foreign debt
it's increased its domestic production
of food you know to what extent can it
at least
manage the situation because of the
measures it has taken
in the short term there are measures
that have been taken and they seem to be
you know
trying to to
to cope with the emergency and the
seriousness of of the impact of
sanctions um
potentially we can also say that you
know a country can be can survive
independently from the rest the case
here is north korea
they can live with very little foreign
trade but at the same time the cost is
very high so it's not too much to know
whether russia will survive russia is a
large country with the lots of as you
mentioned also internal resources is at
what cost will they want to survive
under these conditions and what kind of
you know toll they will take in the
medium in the long term and that is uh
very
very interesting to know i mean russia
for as much as we want to think that you
know we can create what now it has been
called fortress russia
an economy if he wants to grow at this
stage in history is always very
interdependent from others so imagining
russia surviving at this level without
being interconnected with the rest of
the world is utopia all right talking
about glad you mentioned with the rest
of the world because that prompts us to
talk about china to what extent can
china make up for the loss of western
markets to what extent can some of its
systems its currency payment systems
make up for the loss of swift and so on
um this is also one of the questions
that we had and we are discussing now
russia is uh has been increasing its
size with china
again as i've already mentioned the
reserves they went up to 12
from zero virtually in 2017 only in 2021
the trade between russia and china
increased up until 150 150 billion
so russia accounts for uh
[Music]
china counts for an important part of of
russia's trade
the question is whether china is willing
to sacrifice everything else because
china is more important to russia than
the other way around
russia counts only for three five
percent of chinese trade so now with the
situation that we're being seen
any support from chinese from the
chinese state or chinese companies might
be seen very negative from the rest of
the world especially from the us the
european union and the united kingdom
if we see also the dynamics how it's
going some of the chinese companies have
already discontinued
their operations with russia because
they don't want to incur into what what
they have become we became to be known
as secondary sanctions from the united
states so long story short it is
possible that china can provide some
support to russia in this stage but
this would be a very risky move from uh
from china as a state but also from each
individual company that engage with with
russia at the moment
all right thanks so much for your
analysis been great talking to you
francesco
thank you very much for having me on the
show
the invasion of ukraine is helping push
wheat prices to their highest levels in
more than a decade russia and ukraine
together produce more than a quarter of
the world's wheat exports
more than half of the foodstuffs used by
the un's world food program comes from
ukraine priyanka gupta explains
this fertile black soil is known in
ukraine as chernozim
it's made the country the bread basket
of europe
32 million hectares of land is
cultivated every year an area larger
than italy
foodstuffs from corn and sunflower oil
to wheat are shipped from ukraine and
russia around the world
most of those exports are transported
through the black sea
but the ports are now closed and wheat
prices have jumped to a 14-year high
ukraine is the third largest wheat or
corn exporter in the world and the fifth
largest wheat exporter and their the
their wheat especially goes to a lot of
lower and middle income countries around
the world and especially in the middle
east
half of ukraine's wheat exports have
been going to the middle east and north
africa
and governments in the region could
struggle to provide subsidized bread to
their people
egypt the world's biggest importer of
wheat relies on russia and ukraine for
85 percent of its imports
war-torn yemen gets about 40 percent of
its supplies from russia and ukraine
while lebanon counts on ukraine for most
of what it needs
lebanon storage facilities were lost in
the 2020 beirut port blast when grain
silos were destroyed
now it's rushing to find alternatives to
ukrainian wheat
or more tower
if the situation escalates and the wheat
market is halted we have enough for
about a month worth of wheat stored in
the mills and after that we have no
reserves so it's important that we take
this direction seriously
subsidized spread has been a crucial
tool for governments across the middle
east to satisfy their people
rising food prices have previously
caused riots and revolutions and
influenced the 2011 arab spring
and now buyers from asia to africa and
the middle east are scrambling to reduce
their reliance on russia and ukraine for
grain priyanka gupta for counting the
cost
well joining me from london is charlie
robertson charlie is the global chief
economist at renaissance capital thanks
for being with us today charlie so wheat
prices have gone up since the russian
invasion of ukraine
do you think they're going to go up as
much as 50 as some are predicting
well it's possible because what we have
now is not just the fact that there is
going to be no exports through ukraine's
ports you know in the short term uh but
we've also got the question about
how do you ensure uh the the
transportation of any grain coming out
of russia and ukraine given the
sanctions um which ships do you use
given that russian ships are getting
banned by so many countries and so many
large shipping companies are not going
to work with russia um and so whether
it's insurance or shipping
let alone the fact that literally has
the product going to get to the port
during the middle of a war all of that
is is in question right now and i think
that's why we're seeing such a high
spike in in wheat prices what will that
mean to countries that are very
vulnerable to the price of bread
particularly in parts of the middle east
and africa which are reliant to a large
degree
on grain from russia and ukraine yeah i
mean there's a huge egypt is a huge
importer of uh russian ukrainian uh
cereals and it's not the only one north
africa north africa is the biggest part
of russia's trading with africa
and a very large chunk of that is to do
with food so
and food matters food is 40 of the
inflation basket in in in egypt so it
really matters now where i think it's
going to show up is a fiscal cost
because the egyptians as far as i'm
aware haven't yet stopped the subsidy
for small loaves of bread you can buy i
think five each family can go and buy
five small loaves of bread
and very very cheap so it becomes a
fiscal cost to egypt egypt's government
is going to be losing out on this
my hope is that you get a country like
saudi arabia saying well with commodity
prices up here actually we're doing
pretty well uh with oil uh exports
booming in dollars and so we could sub
help out uh egypt and other north
african countries uh with with some
support in that way money from saudi
from higher oil prices going to egypt's
government so it can help subsidize food
that's a big if though isn't it i mean
if this isn't sorted out we could see
countries facing inflation cutting
subsidies potential even threat to
stability right
yeah we looked at this actually in
november because i i
guess we would get issues like this um
and what was interesting about it was
when i looked back at the food price
there's this theory that food price
inflation causes revolution we've had it
from 1789 in the french revolution with
marie antoinette saying let them eat
cakes um and she
that was all about food prices might not
be a lot of cheap in yemen and egypt
though
indeed um indeed but when i look we did
the study on this and political regime
change actually isn't triggered by food
prices what triggers political change is
uh falling per capita gdp that increases
the risk
so if people are actually worse off
the whole country is worse off okay then
then we do have more political risk but
food in itself
isn't
a trigger isn't an extra trigger for
political change i'm talking about food
in general it is interesting talk about
food in general last year
food prices went up in 2021 by what like
28
could we see that trend increase and
perhaps accelerate because of the war in
ukraine
yeah and it's not just about um about
the war it's also about the fact that
fertilizers
potash for example as well that we use
so much to try and increase yields well
the the west sanctioned belarus which is
the one of the world's biggest potash
exporters um and and
and actually sanctioned the company that
that does that and we could see problems
also
using russian fertilizers and they're
big in this space as well because
natural gas is is so helpful for
fertilizer production and fertilizing
russia's bigger natural gas so again
we've got an issue here about how are
people going to get the fertilizers they
need to grow more food so this becomes a
global shock to farmers as well and they
then pass that global shock on to the
rest of the world is there anyone who
can step in and fill the gap fill the
void that we're talking about whether
it's to do with grain wheat or potash
and fertilizers
we are going to rely on good harvests um
good harvest out of canada australia uh
the united states and and to some extent
western europe um so we are going to
have to rely on we're going to have to
be lucky with the weather
um and and secondly then we're going to
have to make sure or hope that countries
like china which went out in 2020 and
massively increased its stock of wheat
and
grain this is part of the reason food
prices started going up in late 2020's
because china wanted to boost its
reserves so you have to make sure that
no one's trying to boost their reserves
which is probably unlikely at this price
level anyway
and that we get good harvest if we get
bad harvests
well then it gets really really tough so
a lot of if a lot of hope and a lot of
luck we're counting on a lot of
variables that we don't entirely control
do we control what about
shipping now we've got to talk about
shipping
it's been disrupted because of the war
whether it's to ukrainian ports or
russian ports because of sanctions or
because of the war itself
what is that going to have on a global
supply chain that was already suffering
because of the pandemic
look i mean it's easiest at this point
to say it's going to be really
it makes life an awful lot tougher and
slower and more complicated for the
russians more than anybody else i mean
arguably if if shipping is going less to
russia then perhaps there's a little bit
more shipping for the rest of the world
and maybe actually that helps on the
supply chain side but the difficulty
about what what's happening right now is
this global shock
um hasn't been can't be priced by the
markets there is simply too much going
on at the moment for us to understand
all the implications um so
we could be having this conversation in
a month's time with a lot more
information at our disposal
right now there's there's just a vast
amount of uncertainty
there is indeed we can agree on that
thanks so much charlie it's been great
talking to you
cheers
the european union has added a
state-owned oil and gas company to its
myanmar sanctions list
rights groups had argued that punishing
myanmar oil and gas enterprise would
take away a crucial source of the
military junta's funds revenues from
natural gas make up about 50 of
myanmar's foreign currency inflows the
military seized power from the elected
civilian government in february
2021.
well joining me now is gareth leather
gareth is a senior asia economist at
capital economics good to have you with
us so we've got a new round of eu
sanctions uh on myanmar what's prompted
this latest round
yeah so i think it makes sense for the
eu to go after myanmar's gas industry i
think gas exports account for about a
third of the total and the sanctions
probably will have some impact i think
that the the issue with myanmar is
also for for the eu and u.s if they want
to try and kind of clamp down and try
and improve human rights as countries
they don't have as much leverage as
myanmar's asian neighbors so china and
taiwan they're by far the biggest source
of investment the biggest market for its
exports and so unless you get those two
countries on board it's unlikely that
that these sanctions are going to have
much of an impact i think what will
probably happen is instead of selling
the uh the gas to a european company
they'll they'll sell it to an asian one
instead and that brings us nicely my
next question was going to be is this
recognition that the sanctions imposed
thus far
have not had the impact the west had
hoped precisely for that point that you
mentioned because the biggest trading
partners well they're in asia not in the
west
yeah i think so so it makes sense when
you're introducing sanctions to kind of
ratchet up the pressure gradually so
they introduced some sanctions you know
a lot long after the um the military
coup a year ago they obviously didn't
have the desired effect that human
rights abuses in the country have got
worse so it makes sense to to increase
the pressure on them but unless the u.s
and eu were really prepared to go kind
of full-scale russia-style sanctions in
terms of cutting any companies that that
dealt with myanmar off the u.s financial
system for example then then they're
going to have limited effects certainly
on the kind of big macro economy they
could have certain effects on you know
certain politicians who were sanctioned
but but i think the overall impact on
the economy probably won't be that
significant
which brings us to the point of the us
do you think the us will follow suit it
hasn't even imposed sanctions on oil and
gas right now has it um well i
i think for starters their their
attention is probably
elsewhere at the moment given events in
ukraine and russia and and how important
that is um but i suspect that
you know certainly that the eu move
increases pressure on the us for the us
to do something to follow suit so i
wouldn't be surprised to see some moves
from the u.s over the next couple of
months but as i said you know eventually
kind of attention is very much elsewhere
at the moment we've also got western oil
companies like total and chevron
announcing their withdrawal what impact
might that have especially when it comes
to technological issues
yeah i think they could have some impact
so these companies there you know
they've invested quite a lot of funds
and resources
into into the sector and they were
hoping that you know the sanctions have
been introduced and the pressure from
the west
would make a difference obviously
they've come to the conclusion now that
they have no other choice but to uh but
to exit the country um
again it's likely that their operations
in myanmar will be taken over by their
attire a chinese or other nation all
right thanks so much gareth good talking
to you
okay bye-bye thank you
and that's our show for this week but
remember you can get in touch with us
via twitter use the hashtag ajctc when
you do or drop us an email counting the
cost of aljazeera.net is our address
there's more for you online at
aljazeera.com ctc that'll take you
straight to our page which has
individual reports links and entire
episodes for you to catch up on
that's it for this edition of candy the
cast i'm sami zaydan from the whole team
here thanks for joining us the news and
al jazeera is next
you